david does it all the time right yeah
i'm obsessed with steroids i stare at
the opponent too much i think most of my
opponents get really uncomfortable
they're like why is he looking at me but
uh yeah um definitely when you play over
the board it's impossible to ignore
what's happening wow what just just
happened there magnus plays bishop takes
pawn whoa he's completely hallucinated
magnus just lost a piece for free and
has he given up he has given up
he has resigned
that you will never see that from a
world champion magnus just took a pawn
but now black will play bishop takes
bishop and black will be a piece up for
free and win the game so magnus just
resigns what is up with the world
champion this is a
huge development eric hansen the second
lowest ranked player in the tournament
the chess dreamer has just beaten with
the black pieces the world champion and
magnus is still sitting looking at this
what is he thinking david i don't know
he must be really surprised and shocked
with himself because it appears like he
hallucinated something yeah sometimes we
talk about chest blindness sometimes you
just make assumptions you just forget
about something for example maybe here
he just forgot his bishop could be
captured by the black light squared
bishop and he's just a piece down